[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BUZZER]
STEPHANIE WONG: Get out of here.
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh!
What are you doing?
STEPHANIE WONG:
JONATHAN CHAM: I'm practicing.
I've got an away game to go to.
STEPHANIE WONG: Oh, away
game for the Warriors?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah!
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
I've got something
that might help you maximize
your experience at the airport.
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh, tell
me more about that.
STEPHANIE WONG: So today we're
talking about Google Cloud's
IoT Core pushing airlines'
data into Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and BigQuery.
JONATHAN CHAM: Interesting.
So what are you collecting,
and what are you
telling you about that?
STEPHANIE WONG: So we're talking
about customer events data,
like whether they checked
bags, how much time you have
in between trips so that you
could possibly get a drink
or upgrade your seats.
JONATHAN CHAM: Nice.
I would love that.
I spend a lot of
time at the airport.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, well,
hopefully, your Dataflow game
is better than your
basketball game 'cause
I don't know what that was.
JONATHAN CHAM: Wow.
Whoa, whoa!
Come on now.
All right.
Let's see it.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Five-minute demo starting now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So before I jump
into the actual demo,
I just wanted to cover
sort of the architecture
that we'll be representing
through this demo today.
We are generating random
data through Compute Engine
and feeding it into a Pub/Sub
topic, which we will then
use Cloud Dataflow to stream
it into BigQuery in real time.
Let's go ahead and just
jump into the actual demo.
So the first thing
I want to show
about how I got
this set up is I'm
going to head over to
Google Cloud Storage, which
I mentioned is how we did
the device simulations
and also where we created
some folders for our Dataflow
pipeline.
So we created a bucket
titled IoT Airlines v1 data.
We created two folders
within this bucket.
And so that's going to
include some information
about our device
simulators here.
And we've also
created another bucket
for our Dataflow pipeline.
So for our Dataflow
pipeline, we've
also included some files here.
And we created two folders
for staging and temp.
It includes spinning
up and shutting down,
Google Compute Engine
instances, and the access
these GSA buckets for both I/O
and temporary file staging.
Now, we've also set up
a Pub/Sub subscription.
So the first thing we do
here is head over to Pub/Sub
and you see here
we've created a topic
and this topic is titled
"Airline Messages."
The type of subscription
we created under this topic
is a pool subscription.
And we've named
it Dataflow here.
So you can see here a publisher
application, in this case,
would be our IoT simulators.
They create a topic in
Pub/Sub, which we've
titled "Airline Messages."
And that's a service that
sends messages to the topic.
Now, going back a little bit,
I'm going to show you IoT Core
because this is also the
component in which we register
our IoT simulators.
What we've done here is we've
registered this right here
called IoT airlines registry.
We've essentially cloned
the git repository,
where we have java files.
And we've compiled
the application here,
upload a JAR file to the storage
bucket that we showed earlier.
This is our registry ID.
It's going to accept in the
form of MQTT and HTTP protocols
in the region US central one.
We have Pub/Sub set up for
this IoT device registration,
which is the one we created
earlier, Airline Messages.
Anytime you register a device
to connect to IoT Core,
you just need to register
it first with Cloud IoT.
It consists of adding a
device to a collection, which
is this registry,
and defining some
of the essential properties,
like we've done here.
The last thing I'm
going to show you
is our Dataflow pipeline
that we've created.
What we've done to build
this Dataflow pipeline
is we've included SDK client
libraries for Java and Python,
plus REST APIs.
And we've essentially
cloned the git repository.
We've updated some files there.
And then we deployed it
directly to Dataflow here.
I'll show you here what
the pipeline we've created
looks like.
So essentially, it's
reading messages,
applying window and techniques
for streaming information
from our IoT devices, and it's
creating a table row and entity
conversion so that
we can actually
push it into other sources
like BigQuery and Datastore.
OK.
Now that we've had this whole
pipeline set up, let's go ahead
into the last step and show
you what it looks like in terms
of the output in BigQuery.
We have our data, event_data.
And this is where all the
data coming out of Dataflow
gets pushed into this table.
So we've created a data
set called IoT Airlines
v2 with our table events_data.
And so you can see here this is
what the schema looks like it.
It includes customer
ID, the event type,
things like customer name.
We also have how many
bags are checked,
how many seats are assigned
under their name, how
long the trip was,
what the origin is,
what the destination.
Let's just do an
example really quickly
of how we can compose a
query on this data set.
Certain routes might be
more likely than others
for certain upsells,
like, for example,
if somebody's flying out at
6:00 in the morning on a Monday,
maybe its a business trip.
You can offer them to buy Wi-Fi.
You can also upsell them if
a customer's carrying bags
or has a connecting
flight, for example.
Maybe they want to upgrade
from coach to first class.
So let's go ahead and just do
an example query of just pulling
customer emails, IDs,
and see if there's
anybody who has actually done
a bag check, for example, so we
can potentially upgrade them.
So let's go ahead and open this.
I have my example query here.
And you just input it
directly into this query box
here and run the query.
We were selecting customer
email, ID from this data set
and table event_data.
And we're looking for customers
who have more than one bag,
and the trip leg
is more than one.
And you can see here this
is just fake generated data.
But in a real-case scenario,
we might have a different list
of customers and their IDs
so that we can immediately
email them and offer
them another service.
JONATHAN CHAM: Whoa,
that was amazing.
Thanks for sharing
all that information.
Now I know when's the best time
to get upgraded because I'm
tired of sitting in coach.
I need to sit first class.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Well, here's to riding in style.
Thanks again, everyone,
for watching Take5 with us.
Please comment, like,
and subscribe below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]